[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes là pour stimuler
notre curiosité
je voudrais moi ce soir vous raconter
une histoire qui est une réalité
je voudrais vous emmener dans un peuple
un peuple qui avait la tête nos logis
nous avons parlé ce soit de la
technologie vous savez qu'aujourd'hui
c'est un terme sur toutes les bouches
que ça le digital le numérique mais il
se fait et ce peuple
je voudrais vous parler avec la
technologie
et ça fait que soir
je fus hausse je voudrais que vous
gardiez ce nom parce que toute
l'histoire tourne autour du fioul qui
est une expatriée et à bord de son
bolivar son bateau s'appelle donc boli
bas
il fit naufrage au large de ce peuple
il a été retrouvé par un autochtone qui
est allé appelé les habitants du village
et ils ont transporté vers un premier
espère
le mieux et espère
tu poses
sept expatriés ne marchait plus parce
qu'il avait mal aux pieds
alors respect j'ajuste le pied par trois
fois et il dit monsieur vous avez être
active automatiquement vieux concept
étranger s'exclamant ai dit ça c'est de
la radiographie
[Musique]
parce que chez moi il ya ce genre
d'incident il faut faire forcément
c'était à main afin de voir où avant de
voir le nombre de factures subie par le
pied mais laisse pas 10 4 h
alors le périple du fus repousse au
massa dans ce village
le monsieur prépara donc avec de la gym
bien sûr de bois les mobilisations du
pied l'étranger s'attendait
à un système de plâtre pour immobiliser
son pied mais juste avec du bois de
l'asile et d'autres feuilles l'espère
immobilisa donc le pied fracturé et de
bandas à notre trajet je cause de se
reposer le lendemain ils étaient là
cailly des clio ii et au voleur au
voleur au voleur
donc des habitants du village a été vue
ni voir l'espère parce qu'il ya eu vol
dans le village alors réveillé par ses
cris il veut également dans la grande
salle
6 t à la découverte du voleur parce que
les habitants voulaient samba qui a
roulé ainsi donc l'espère sort son
nationale qui a composé essentiellement
d'une calebasse et et deux ingrédients
bio parce que je suis pas l'espère
alors après avoir préparé son nationale
il appela
un enfant encore puceau et lui demanda
de regarder vers la fin regarda est dit
ce nom mais qui abolit
robert a escaladé le mur y avait trois
heures et a pris le pas et à je le vois
il appuie également la route et s'est
retourné alors l'espèce demandant qu un
enfant nommé ou actuellement l'enfant
fils juste et fait l'objet actuellement
dans la mousse
il suppose l'étranger parce que c'est de
lui il s'agit
qui vous dit ça c'est de la
vidéosurveillance parce qu'il ne
comprend pas comment on puisse retracer
les faire passer à travers une telle
masse donc la calebasse a servi c'est
esther pourquoi pour retracer les faits
et gestes du voleur vous la nommèrent
dépassé par les événements
il décida de se promener un peu alors
arrivés vers une case
une femme il gémissait
qu'elle voulait mettre au monde un bébé
tout le monde courait qui oppose savait
son métier
c'est un défi mieux ailleurs reconnu
tout de suite
7les d'angoise il se précipita à la
casse est dit mais la dame perle du sang
et sur la mine à l'hôpital il regarde un
peu du maire la tête du bébé
la tête est trop grosse ça ne peut pas
sauter là c'est tentant ne peut pas
sorti il fait la césarienne donc tout de
suite qui oppose notre ami laisse pas
trier il a fait le diagnostic il a monté
ce vendredi mais il faut évacuer la dame
[Applaudissements]
y avait une maman qu'on appelle maman
béni qui fit son entrée avec une si tu
sais tu sais tu à base de pair
des poches alors maman bene mais la
situe à la dame
je vous assure deux minutes plus tard à
sa sortie je suis au poste histoire ça
c'est de la césarienne qu'il était
dépassé par les événements quelle drôle
de peuples alors il suffit à me avec
nous tentons pour mieux comprendre et 10
mai mon ami la fois passé ce que j'ai vu
rappaz ouvre le samedi matin et cet
amour tonnes lui dit tu n'as rien vu
c'est parce que celle qui a perdu ses
effets ne s'est pas dotée réellement de
notation qui existe parce que
chez nous ici
quand vous revient et il vole où il a
envie de vous les et plan le ballet
commence par balles et il balaie jusqu'à
ce que le propriétaire de la maison
je suis mais mais mais tu opposes dit
mais ça c'est un filet de rétention
[Applaudissements]
c'est un élément métallique 13 chez moi
téléfilm abricots mer sur les murs pour
empêcher le voleur de sa fille
alors
procos décidant d'ouvrir un cahier il a
commencé par noté
deux semaines après c'était la fête du
village le white et là les notaires ou
le monde chantait il y avait un rituel
un peu particulier où douze hommes
devraient se mettre debout cavalaire
cuvier tous les fusillés
comme il est l étranger le seul étranger
dans le village en ce moment le roi dit
qu'ils arrêtent ranger à vous l'honneur
que ne le fusil mu ye ses jardins et aux
causes le garçon a mis ce serait atteint
est ce que je pourrais faire ceci alors
qu'à mes yeux est pas le physique
si vous étiez 12 la fête du dj goodka il
ouvrit les yeux
les deux hommes étaient encore debout et
10 16 de la loi anti balles
ça c'est tout technologique esi c'est
moi ou on pas dégelé et quand il ça ne
vient pas dans le corps ces gens là elle
et son amie de lui dis bien sûr
parce qu'ils ont été préparés et si
celle-ci cinq ans moi je sais pas auprès
d'un essai personnel alors pour
certaines pas la thèse alors
course
penne sa dépouille bête il machin soit
quand ils en comptent bientôt bientôt
kindy mais monsieur vous n'avez pas
mariés depuis le matin vous vous aviez
su que je n'ai pas mangé de noms mais je
vois mes fiocco de libellules à ses
escales est debout
c'est ce qu'à l'est parce que s'il
arrive à voir dans mon ventre
c'est réellement il peut déceler les
anomalies qui a d'amendements cela veut
dire que ce peuple avait un scanner ce
peuple avait des artisanes ce peuple
avait également beaucoup d'autres
technologies comme ce qui va suivre
fatigué de son séjour dans ce village
il a souhaité voir sa famille et bien
son ami c'est seulement je suis fatigué
mon épouse me manque
mes enfants mes marques la mairie dit
mais qui a réellement envie de les voir
réellement voir la famille du tueur
présumé je le veux je le veux bien
alors ton ami la menace sur notre espère
un autre s est à nouveau là haut le
monde juste
un miroir
appel nathalie michel et hot hollywood
il voit sa famille à table en train de
manger qui dit ça cela regarde ça c'est
la rockhal parce qu'il regagnait sa
famille magique et vous allez constater
aujourd'hui que nos portables sont dotés
vers ma joie dans ce peuple avait déjà
la techno ce peuple utilisait déjà des
techniques pour le fasse
ces mythes élargie si aujourd'hui moi je
suis me roy et blague et je vous appelez
que paient les prévienne je lui parle il
me répond
je voudrais bien continué parce qu'il y
en a tellement
sur ma curiosité
né à aller chercher toutes les
technologies qui existent aujourd'hui
mais qui existait au sein de ce couple
alors pour finir qui oppose vous la
rentrée
finale et n'a vu ni voiture dans ce
village ni moto y avait rien et demande
à son arc comment belle rentrée
la mule mais ça c'est une affaire de
minutes
parce que chez nous
et suffit de 10 là où tu vois on met
ensemble de singles et bien tu vas te
retrouver là-bas et 10 as et le compagne
de voyage seul avion et ce qui est bien
dans son peuple c'est un viol ou pas eu
de casse jamais de classe
alors tu au cos décida
deux parties des revenus ou payer juste
à temps pour commercialiser ses
savoir-faire l'application donc il va
revenir bientôt dans ce pub pour prendre
ses savoir faire
les transformer en application et les
revendre encore aux habitants du secteur
et ce peuple c'est l'afrique
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]